.
KUDOS MR. CLAPTON.
GUTFELD NEXT
>> YES, IT DOES REQUIRE VOTER
ID.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THAT.
AND I SAY GENTLY, TO MY
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS FROM TEXAS,
IF YOU DON'T, IF YOU DON'T SEE
THE NEED FOR THAT, THEN THERE
ARE ONE OR TWO CIRCUMSTANCES
HERE.
EITHER YOU'RE SO DUMB YOU LOSE
YOUR PLACE DURING SEX, OR YOU
WANT TO CHEAT
>> Greg: WHEN I LOSE MY PLACE
DURING SEX, I JUST REFRESH THE
BROWSER WINDOW.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪
>> Greg: I WAS JUST KIDDING.
OKAY?
WILD CRIME SPREADS LIKE A VIRUS
ON A PLANE FULL OF DEMOCRATS.
AT LEAST WE KNOW TRUE JUSTICE IS
BEING DONE.
A FLORIDA MAN HAS BEEN SENTENCED
TO EIGHT MONTHS IN JAIL FOR
BREACHING THE SENATE CHAMBER ON
JANUARY 6TH CARRYING A TRUMP
FLAG.
THE ONLY SURPRISE, HE DIDN'T GET
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE.
NOW, WE'RE NOT LIBERAL SO WE GET
IT.
YOU DO THE CRIME, YOU DO THE
TIME.
GOT THAT FROM BERETTA.
FOR ANYBODY WATCHING WHO'S
YOUNGER THAN 75, BERETTA, HE HAD
A PARROT.
NO?
DOESN'T RING A BELL?
BUT YOU CAN STILL QUESTION THE
PENALTY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IF YOU WERE BLM,
IT WOULD BE A OKAY.
BUT IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THEY
OVERDID THE SENTENCING.
IN FACT, THEY EVEN ADMIT IT AS
ONE ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY
SAID, IT WILL SEND A LOUD AND
CLEAR MESSAGE SO THERE WON'T BE
A NEXT TIME.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO WORRY WHEN YOU
BECOME A MESSAGE.
BECAUSE THEN YOU'RE SCREWED.
IT'S A THREAT LIKE FINDING A
HORSE'S HEAD IN YOUR BED OR A
BOOK SIGNED BY ANDREW CUOMO.
SENTENCING SHOULD ONLY BE FOR
THE CRIME, AND NOT FOR A GREATER
MESSAGE, ESPECIALLY A MESSAGE SO
MANUFACTURED.
YOU HEARD IT YOURSELF.
THE BREACH WAS THE WORST THING
SINCE THE BEHINDBURG, THE JFK
ASSASSINATION AND SYNCHRONIZED
SWIMMING ALL ROLLED INTO ONE.
>> I BELIEVE THAT JANUARY 6TH
WAS, IN EFFECT, A SECOND KIND OF
CIVIL WAR.
>> THE WORST ATTACK ON OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>>THE WORST ATTACK ON OUR
>> THE MOST SERIOUS THREAT TO
OUR DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL
WAR.
>> IT IS THE WORST ASSAULT THAN
THE CIVIL WAR.
>> JANUARY 6TH WAS WORSE THAN
9/11 BECAUSE IT'S CONTINUED TO
RIP OUR COUNTRY APART.
>> THE ASSAULT ON FREE ELECTIONS
IS SUCH A THREAT.
WE'RE FACING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THREAT OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>> Greg: WOW, IT'S LIKE THEY'RE
ALL WORKING FROM THE SAME
SCRIPT.
TALK ABOUT SENDING A MESSAGE.
AND, MAN, THEY ARE ON MESSAGE.
THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS, AND
EVEN THE JUDGES.
BUT WHY SEND A MESSAGE ABOUT
THIS AND NOT OTHER THINGS
KILLING PEOPLE.
NOT TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
OR MISENDERING YOUR FRIEND
DANNY.
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ARRESTED IN
RIOTS LAST YEAR ALL HAD THEIR
CHARGES DISMISSED AND THESE
INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO THREW
PROJECTILES AT COPS BURNED
PRIVATE PROPERTY ASSAULTED
CIVILIANS AND LOOTING AND
DESTRUCTION OF BUSINESSES.
IN MINNEAPOLIS ALONE YOU HAVE
OVER A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES, 1500 PROPERTIES
DAMAGED, 150 BUILDINGS SET ON
FIRE, COUNTLESS POLICE INJURED.
MAYBE IT'S HARD TO PROSECUTE
MOBS EN MASSE, BUT IMAGINE IN
THE GOVERNMENT HAD DEVOTED THE
TIME AND RESOURCES TO PUNISH
THESE THUGS WITH THE SAME
INTENSITY THEY DEVOTED TO
HUNTING DOWN TRESPASSING
GRANNIES WHO DIDN'T WEAR MASKS.
STORES COULD BE OPEN AGAIN IN
MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS.
PARKED CARS WOULDN'T GET AIR
CONDITIONED BY BROKEN WINDOWS.
WE COULD GET MS-13 DOWN TO MS-5
OR SIX.
BUT THEY DIDN'T.
INSTEAD THEY EGGED ON THE
CIVILIANS TO NARC ON EACH OTHER,
TURNED AMERICA INTO A NATION OF
MAFIA VETS BECAUSE THEY HATE
ANYTHING THAT SMELLS OF TRUMP.
SO IGNORING THE HELPLESS CRIES
OF CITIZENS OUR GOVERNMENT
CREATED AN ARTIFICIAL DANGER TO
KEEP US DIVIDED THAT AMERICA IS
NOW AT THE MERCY OF A WHITE
SUPREMACIST MOVEMENT NOT A CRIME
WAVE PARALYZING CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
YET WE KNOW WHICH IS REAL AND
WHICH ISN'T.
EVEN THE JUDGE WHO SENTENCED THE
CAPITOL HILL GUY USED THE SAME
EXACT WORDS FROM THE MEDIA.
JUDGE RANDOLPH NOTES TOLD THE
GUY ALTHOUGH YOU WERE ONLY ONE
MEMBER OF A LARGER MOB YOU
PARTICIPATED IN A LARGER EVENT
THAT THREATENED THE CAPITOL AND
DEMOCRACY ITSELF.
YOU CAN SAY THAT ABOUT THE CRIME
WAVE BUT THEY WON'T.
BUT THAT SENTIMENT ABOUT
JANUARY 6TH HAD ALREADY BEEN PUT
INTO PLAY OVER AND OVER BY THE
MEDIA, THAT THIS DAY THREATENED
DEMOCRACY.
OF COURSE, THE CAPITOL REOPENED
AND OUR DEAR LEADERS WERE BACK
PRETENDING TO WORK WITHIN HOURS.
MEANWHILE, COUNTLESS BUSINESSES
WILL NEVER COME BACK SINCE THE
CRIME WAVE BEGAN.
THERE ARE THE DEAD WHO PAID THE
PRICE FOR THE COWARD IS OF
LIBERAL LEADERS.
REMEMBER DAVID CORN?
THE MEDIA WON'T.
GOOD FOR YOU JUDGE, YOU GOT THE
MISGUIDED NUTTER TOSSED INTO THE
CLINK.
YOU SAVED DEMOCRACY, NOT REALLY
YOU JUST PAR ROTTED THE MEDIA'S
MESSAGE WHICH IS WHO CARES ABOUT
THE CRIMINAL GANGS, WE GOT THE
DUMB WHITE PROTESTER COVERED.
SAN FRANCISCO LOCALS DESCRIBING
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO RUN A BUSINESS
NOW OVERRUN BY LOOTERS.
>> THEY ARE LITERALLY JUST
TAKING IT FROM THE STORE.
THEY ARE TAKING IT, GRABBING IT
AND RUNNING.
>> THE BOTTOM WINDOW IS NOW
BOARDED UP BECAUSE SOMEONE BROKE
INTO OUR STORE ONE NIGHT.
>> VERY COMMON, TAKE ANYTHING
THEY CAN GET.
>> THEY CASUALLY COME IN, GRAB
WHAT THEY NEED AND WALK OUT.
>> I RAN UP TO STOP THEM AND
THEY KIND OF THREATENED EVERYONE
HERE AND THEN THEY TOOK WHAT
THEY WANTED TO AND LEFT.
>> THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF NOW REALLY BAD
>> Greg: REALLY BAD.
BUT I BET THEY'RE ALL REALLY
RELIEVED THEY SENTENCED THE GUY
FROM JANUARY 6TH.
ALL THOSE THIEVES MUST HAVE BEEN
FLAKEY TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
AOC WILL TELL YOU THOSE
CRIMINALS ARE ONLY STEALING
BREAD TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES AS
THEY FUNNEL THE GOODS THROUGH AN
ELABORATE FENCING NETWORKS
MAKING MILLIONS FOR AS I
UNDERSTAND INDICATES.
SHE HAS GONE QUIET ON THAT.
THE GOVERNMENT MADE A CHOICE NOT
BASED ON JUSTICE BUT FEAR
TERRIFIED OF THE ELITE ACTIVIST
CLASS THEY DECIDED TO LET THE
MOB STEAL WHILE LOCKING UP CRACK
POTS IN FUNNY HATS.
THE GUY DIDN'T HURT ANYONE OR
DAMAGE PROPERTY.
WHAT IS GOING TO TELL HIS CELL
MATE HE'S IN FOR?
LOITERING.
COLLATERAL DAMAGE FOR BEING A
TRUMP SUPPORTER.
THE SECURITY OF A COUNTRY IS NOW
LESS IMPORTANT THAN SHEAR
POLITICAL REVENGE.
THEY WANT YOU CRUSHED LIKE THE
WHEELS LIKE THE WHEELS ON BRIAN
STELTER'S DESK CHAIR.
>> DAM
>> Greg: I KNOW.
SORRY.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE HAS TO SAY.
♪♪
SURE IS GREAT TAKING A WALK AND
BEING AT PEACE WITH MY THOUGHTS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S SO STRANGE THAT
THOSE SAME POLITICIANINGS WHO
PUSHED FOR LOCKED DOWNS AND THEN
ENCOURAGED THOSE VIOLENT
PROTESTS THAT LED TO THE
DESTRUCTION OF CITIES NOW WANT
TO DECRIMINALIZED SHOPLIFTING
AND PROPERTY CRIMES WHICH WILL
HURT SMALL BUSINESSES.
I MEAN, I JUST CAN'T THINK OF
ANY REASON FOR IT AT ALL.
DON'T SAY GREAT RESET IT WILL
MAKE YOU SEEM CRAZY.
>> DON'T SAY GREAT RESET IT WILL
DID I JUST SAY SOMETHING?
♪
>> Greg: HE IS CRAZY.
BUT I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY
BLACK MALE HAS TO SAY.
♪♪
>> WHAT IT IS, WHAT IT WAS, WHAT
IT SHALL BE.
THIS I TYRUS.
ENOUGH SAID.
WHAT?
YES.
WHAT HAPPENED JANUARY 6TH?
EVERYONE INVOLVED THAT WAS
ARRESTED AND WAS SEEN ON VIDEO
IS BEING GIVEN SOME STIFF
SENTENCES.
AS THEY SHOULD.
IT WAS A BAD THING.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN WHAT ABOUTISM
AND I'M NOT TAKING ONE FROM THE
OTHER BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
EVERYONE THAT BROKE INTO A
BUILDING, BURNED DOWN A
BUILDING, STOLE A BOTTLE OF
WATER UP TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN DAMAGES
TO STORES AND BUILDINGS, SHOULD
ALSO BE GIVEN THE SAME STIFF
PENALTIES.
JUST PUTTING IT OUT THERE.
FAIR IS FAIR.
THE LAW IS THE LAW.
LEAVE POLITICS OUT OF IT.
THAT'S IT.
♪
>> Greg: SO ONE LAST QUIZ.
WHAT IS A TRUE THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY?
CITIZENS BREACHING THE CAPITOL?
MAYBE.
OR A GOVERNMENT ENLISTING
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO CURB YOUR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH WHILE TURNING
YOUR NEIGHBORS AND RELATIVES
INTO A BUNCH OF SQUEALERS?
OR HOW ABOUT THAT SAME
GOVERNMENT PRETENDING A CRIME
WAVE IS MERELY A DISTRACTION
FROM UNSEEN AND UNNAMED WHITE
TERRORISTS.
I THINK YOU ALREADY KNOW THAT
ANSWER.
THE PROBLEM IS, DOES IT MATTER?
♪♪
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
SHE'S DONE MORE INTERVIEWS THAN
A HIRING MANAGER AT WENDY'S.
FOX BUSINESS CORESPONDENT, SUSAN
LI!
HE'S OUR NUMBER ONE SOURCE FOR
NAMES STARTING WITH J.
RETIRED US MARINE CORPS BOMB
TECHNICIAN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOHNNY JOEY JONES.
CHEERLEADER LAWYER PUNDIT.
SHE'S WON MORE HATS THAN FANS AT
THE KENTUCKY DERBY.
OUTNUMBERED HOST EMILY COMPAGNO.
AND HIS ANIMAL TATTOOS ARE LIFE
SIZE.
MY SIDE KICK ON FOX NATION,
TYRUS.
>> SUSAN WELCOME TO THE SHOW,
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU.
>> OH, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> YOU'RE UP TOO EARLY IN THE
MORNING SO I DON'T SEE YOU THEN.
YOU'RE AT FOX BUSINESS.
WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE IS IT WHEN
NO ONE GETS ARRESTED OR CHARGED
FOR LOOTING?
>> WELL, WE USE DOUBLE STANDARDS
IN WASHINGTON.
REMEMBER WHEN THAT STORY BROKE
THAT NANCY PELOSI WAS WORTH
$150 MILLION AND THAT'S BECAUSE
SHE'S BEEN BUYING STOCK.
HER HUB HAS BEEN BUYING STOCK
THAT HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY POLICY
THAT SHE MAKES.
NOW, IF THAT HAPPENED ON WALL
STREET, PEOPLE WOULD BE THROWN
AWAY, BE PUT IN JAIL PROBABLY
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES FOR
WHITE CORPORATE CRIME.
BUT IN DC, YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS
LEAK A DOUBLE STANDARD FOR
OTHERS, RIGHT?
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, YOU GO IN
AND BUY STOCK WHENEVER YOU FEEL
LIKE IT.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
SO YOU HAVE A DOUBLE STANDARD
HERE THEN IN WHICH OBVIOUSLY
JANUARY 6TH THESE PEOPLE GO TO
JAIL, BUT A SLOW-ROLLING CRIME
WAVE, YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH
ANYTHING.
YOU CAN GO IN AND SHOP LIFT.
>> RIGHT.
MY GRANDPA USED TO OWN A
CONVENIENCE STORE SO HE WAS
RUNNING AWAY FROM CIVIL WAR AND
THIS WAS HOW HE MADE HIS NEW
LIFE IN THE NEW LAND.
AND WHEN I WAS LITTLE, I DIDN'T
KNOW IT AT THE TIME, BUT HE WAS
ACTUALLY BEING ROBBED.
I WAS A LITTLE KID I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
HE TOLD ME TO GO BACK INTO THE
KITCHEN.
>> I REMEMBER THAT DAY.
>> YOU WERE THERE
>> Greg: YES, YES, YES.
>> MY GRANDPA WAS HERE TRYING TO
MAKE A NEW LIFE, RIGHT, TRYING
TO BUILD A BUSINESS.
AND WHEN THINGS ARE STOLEN HE
LOSES MONEY AND HURTS HIM IN THE
END.
THE INDIVIDUALS ARE JUST TRYING
TO EARN A LIVING GETS HURT BY
SHOPLIFTING AND CRIME
>> Greg: THEN THEY LEAVE, HURTS
THE BUSINESSES, THEY CLOSE UP,
THE BUSINESSES AREN'T THERE AND
THE BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES
SLOWLY DIE EMILY.
THEY SLOWLY DIE.
YOU WERE A CHEERLEADER FOR THE
RAIDERS SO YOU'RE USED TO
DEFENDING CRIMINALS.
>> EVERYONE IS INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY
>> Greg: EXCEPT FOR THE RAIDERS.
>> UGHH
>> Greg: SO, ANYWAY, YOU ARE A
LAWYER.
WHY DO YOU THINK THERE IS THIS
DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> I DON'T KNOW, BUT IT KILLS ME
TOO JUST AS A HUMAN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE AN ATTORNEY
TO SEE THE INJUSTICE HERE AND
WHAT'S HARD FOR ME TO SWALLOW AS
WELL AS A CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY IS THE FACT THAT THE
PROSECUTORS ARE FAILING TO DO
THEIR JOB.
THE SYSTEM EXISTS IN A CERTAIN
WAY SO THAT IT PROTECTS BOTH
SIDES.
SO THAT, YES, THE DEFENDANTS ARE
PROTECTED BUT SO ARE THE
VICTIMS.
THERE ARE ADVOCATES AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF EVERYONE IN
THE SYSTEM IN THE COURT.
BUT HERE WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THE COMPLETE EROSION OF THAT
DUTY ON THE PROSECUTORIAL SIDE.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE SLOW DYING.
WE WATCHED BEFORE OUR EYES
PORTLAND BURN TO THE GROUND
ESSENTIALLY OVER A HUNDRED
STRAIGHT DAYS OF RIOTS AND
LOOTING AND FIRES.
AND OF ALL THE FEDERAL CRIMES
THAT WERE REFERRED FOR
PROSECUTION, THE DA DROPPED HALF
OF THEM.
AND OF THOSE HALF, NONE WENT TO
TRIAL AND INSTEAD THE ONES THAT
GOT ANY TYPE OF SENTENCE, IT WAS
LITERALLY DOING COMMUNITY
SERVICE OR, QUOTE, ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO VOTE.
THOSE WERE FOR CRIMES LIKE
ASSAULTING A FEDERAL OFFICER,
BURNING DOWN A FEDERAL BUILDING
TO THE TUNE OF $3 MILLION THAT
EARLIER YOU MENTIONED REVENGE IN
YOUR INTRO, AND IN THOSE RIOTS,
I WILL NEVER FORGET ONE OF THOSE
RIOTER'S SCIENCE SAID WE DON'T
WANT BIDEN, WE WANT REVENGE
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
WHAT'S UP J CUBED?
HOW ARE YOU?
HAPPY BIRTHDAY
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YAY.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT?
I TURNED OLD ENOUGH TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT TODAY.
>> Greg: EXCELLENT.
>> BUT I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT
UNLESS TAMMY DUCT WORTH DOES.
THAT WAY I NO ONE CAN SAY I USED
MY LEGS TO WIN AND SHE DOESN'T
GET TO.
OKAY.
I HAVE TO DO IT.
>> HE LIKES JOKING AROUND.
YOU CAN LAUGH.
>> THAT WAS NOT A JOKE.
THAT WAS NOT A JOKE.
>> NO ONE HERE THOUGHT IT WAS
FUNNY THAT HE CROSSED HIS LEG
AND THEN UNCROSSED IT IN A SIGH
OF RELIEF?
NO ONE SAW THAT?
I THOUGHT IT WAS FUNNY.
SORRY.
JUST PUTTING IT OUT THERE
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO THROW OUT
A CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT I CAME
UP WITH, SO IT'S PROBABLY TRUE.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT ALL THE
PROTESTS AND RIOTS SUDDENLY JUST
WENT AWAY AND NOTHING WAS
SOLVED?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE IT WAS A
FAUCET THAT WAS TURNED ON AND
THEN TURNED ON OF.
>> I MEAN, CORONAVIRUS.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT GET
EXACERBATED AND GO AWAY, AND
THEN MAYBE COME BACK WHEN IT'S
POLITICALLY ADVANTAGEOUS.
HERE'S ONE, THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN, WE DIDN'T FIGHT A
20 YEAR WAR WE FOUGHT TWO TEN
YEAR WARS BECAUSE WE HAD
MIDTERMS AND PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS
>> Greg: GOOD POINT.
>> YOU SAID EARLIER, WHY DOES
THIS DOUBLE STANDARD EXIST.
IT'S OBVIOUS WHY IT EXISTS.
IT'S POLITICAL INTIMIDATION.
THIS IS ACTUALLY WHAT IT IS.
YOU CANNOT, YOU CANNOT CREATE AN
ARGUMENT TO ME THAT THAT WHITE,
DUMB, JUST -- I CAN'T REMEMBER
>> Greg: LEGO MODELS?
THE CAPITOL BUILDING?
>> MOSELIUM TO CORRUPTION.
>> I WOULD HAVE GOT IT.
>> SO YOU CANNOT TELL ME THAT
THAT IS MORE A SYMBOL OF
DEMOCRACY THAN EVERY TOWN SQUARE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> AMEN.
>> THAT'S WHAT BOTHERS ME.
HERE'S THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
THAT EXIST IN TOWN SQUARES, THE
PEOPLE THAT GO AROUND THEIR
LIVES ARE RULE FOLLOWERS, SO
THEY'RE EASY TO PUNISH.
BUT THOSE WHO AREN'T RULE
FOLLOWERS AREN'T EASY TO PUNISH.
THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
YOU CAN COME FOR THEM BUT DON'T
COME FOR US.
DON'T COME TO CAPITOL HILL.
GO TO SMALL TOWNS BUT DON'T COME
FOR US, THE RULING CLASS
>> Greg: THAT REALLY PISSES ME
OFF THE WAY YOU FRAME IT.
I MEAN IT'S TRUE.
>> REAL AS IT GETS.
>> NAILED IT
>> Greg: IT PISSES THE HELL OUT
OF ME.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT JJJ, TRIPLE
J, IS RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING,
TYRUS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU SAID IT.
YOU MADE A REALLY GOOD POINT AS
THE ANGRY BLACK MALE THAT
CONSISTENCY IS WHAT MATTERS.
>> YES, BUT WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF A CON.
I'M PIGGYBACKING OFF WHAT HE'S
SAYING.
WE'RE PLAYING THE SAME GAME WE
JUST CHANGED THE RULES.
NOW YOU HAVE PEOPLE COMING OUT
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT'S PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHO HAVE BEEN ELECTED BY
MASSES MUCH DIFFERENT COLORS
SAYING THINGSER AS BAD AS THEY
EVER WERE AND YOU CONDITION
PROVE OR DENY IT AND IF YOU
CHALLENGE IT WE'RE PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
SO YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
INFLUENCE PEOPLE WHO JUST WANT
SOMETHING TO BURN DOWN.
AND YOU'RE NOT CONCERNED WIND
WHAT THE REACTIONS OF IT IS, AND
THE MORE THAT THEY DO IT, THE
MORE THINGS YOU CAN SAY.
AND THEN AT SOME POINT, WHEN THE
JIG IS UP AND YOU'VE GOT ENOUGH
MONEY, BECAUSE EVERYONE WHO'S
SPEAKING ABOUT THE INJUSTICE OF
THIS COUNTRY IS MAKING A LOT OF
MONEY OFF SPEAKER FEES AND
DONATIONS TO THE CAUSE AND
MILLIONS, AND EVENTUALLY IT WILL
BE TRILLIONS, TO MAKE ALL THIS
MONEY TO SOLVE THE RIDDLE THAT
THEY ALREADY KNOW THE ANSWER TO.
THEY'RE JUST TAKING THE PLAY
BOOK FROM A TIME WHEN THINGS
WERE REALLY BAD, WHEN THERE WAS
A JIM CROW ERROR.
WHEN THERE WAS A HUGE DIFFERENCE
IF A BROTHER WALKED INTO THE
STORE AND HE STOLE A PIECE OF
BREAD TO FEED HIS FAMILY THEY
WOULD GET 20 YEARS, NO PATROL.
NOW, WHEN A WHITE PERSON DOES
IT, WALKS IN AND DOES THE SAME
THING, HE WOULD HAVE GOT A,
WELL, HE NEEDED FOOD.
HE NEEDED IT FOR HIS FAMILY.
SO I RESPECT THEM FOR EVERYTHING
THE COURAGE TO GO IN AND TAKE
WHAT'S HIS FOR HIS FAMILY.
WE JUST CHANGED THE ROLES NOW.
NOW IT'S WHITE AMERICA THAT'S
THE PROBLEM.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT
EQUALITY, THEY WANT OPPORTUNITY
AND ADVANTAGE.
WHEN YOU HAVE OPPORTUNITY AND
ADVANTAGE YOU CAN PROFIT FROM IT
AND AS LONG AS IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
IN THEIR YARD WHERE EVERYONE
GETS CRAZY SENTENCES, THEY CAN
EAT THEMSELVES AND THEN YOU CAN
PROFIT FROM IT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE HE A
SEEING IN THIS COUNTRY, WE JUST
SWITCHED ROLES
>> Greg: FLIPPED THE SCRIPT.
>> AND WHITE PEOPLE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE BEING
CONDITIONED NOT TO FIGHT BACK
AND YOU GUYS NEED TO FIGHT BACK.
AND I END WITH THIS.
I AM SO SORRY YOUR GRANDFATHER
LEFT THE CIVIL WAR, CAME TO
AMERICA, LOW AND BEHOLD TO FIND
OUT IT'S WORSE THAN A CIVIL WAR.
SORRY
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> THAT'S THE WOKE THING.
WHERE YOU AT?
>> IT'S WORSE.
HE GOT HERE, THIS IS WORSE THAN
WHERE I LEFT.
SORRY.
SORRY YOU GUYS HAD TO DEAL WITH
THIS
>> Greg: UP NEXT THEY SAID SCREW
THE CIVILIA